Queen Lion of the Animal Kingdom is displeased.
She recently introduced elections for the
office of king using the first post the post
voting system.
While her Realm started out as a healthy democracy
with many parties running candidates for king,
it quickly devolved into two party rule, with
the citizens not liking either one but trapped
within the system because of a problem called
the spoiler effect.
However, one of Queen Lion’s subjects from
a distant land, Wallaby, has a solution: The
Alternative Vote.
What’s the difference?
To find out, lets follow one voter on election
day, Red Squirrel, under both systems.
There are five candidates running for king,
two members of the big parties Gorilla and
Leopard and three other candidates, Turtle,
Owl and Tiger.
Under first-past-the-post Red Squirrel gets
a ballot where he picks just one candidate.
Red Squirrel Really likes Turtle and even
campaigned for him. However he knows that
his new neighbor, Grey Squirrel, is voting
Gorilla.
And what, starts to wonder Red Squirrel, about
all the other animals? Who are they going
to vote for?
The debates on Animal News Network only had
the big parties, so Red Squirrel thinks it’s
going to be a close race between Gorilla and
Leopard.
While he’s indifferent toward Gorilla he
is deathly afraid of Leopard.
Because he can only pick a single candidate,
he gives his one vote to Gorilla in hopes
of preventing Leopard from becoming king.
This is strategic voting, and it’s a necessity
under First Past the Post.
But now it’s time to look at the Alternative
Vote, which wallaby explains to Red Squirrel.
Instead of picking one and only one candidate,
he can rank them in order of his most favorite
to his least.
He goes into the voting both and gets the
same ballot as before, but now puts Turtle
as his first choice, Owl as his second and
Gorilla, third.
He dislikes Leopard and Tiger equally so he
stops filling in his ballot and drops it in
the box.
At this point, Red Squirrel doesn’t care
exactly what happens, he has other things
on his mind and heads off. But you, dear citizen,
want to know how the votes are counted so
here goes:
Turtle, beloved though he is with some of
the citizenry, comes in last place with only
5% and he is eliminated from the race.
Because the voters ranked their candidates
in order, we can know what would have happened
if Turtle didn’t run.
Without Turtle, voters like Red Squirrel,
would have picked Owl instead, so their votes
are transferred to her as though Turtle was
never in the race at all.
This is why Alternative Vote is sometimes
called Instant Runoff Voting. It’s able
to simulate a bunch of elections where the
least popular candidate is eliminated after
each round without all the time and expense
it would take to run a bunch of campaigns,
one after another.
The Alternative Vote method keeps eliminated
the least popular candidate until someone
either wins a majority or is the only one
left.
As no one has a majority yet, the next lowest
candidate, Tiger, is eliminated. Tiger voters
listed leopard as their second choice, so
she gets Tiger’s votes.
In the last round, Gorilla is eliminated.
Gorilla voters listed Owl as their second
choice, so Owl gets those votes, wins a majority,
so is crowed king.
The alternative vote is a better system because
it produces winners that a larger number of
voters agree on.
While the Alternative Vote does have flaws
it’s important to note that any problem
AV has, first past the post shares.
They’re both susceptible to gerrymandering,
they aren’t proportional systems, they can’t
guarantee a Condorcet winner (which math geeks
hate but there isn’t time to explain here),
and over time they both trend toward two main
parties.
That being said, Alternative Vote has a huge
advantage that first past the post lacks and
makes it a mathematically superior method:
no spoiler effect!
Imagine this election: the two big candidates
are running, Gorilla and Leopard, and Leopard
looks set to win 55% to 45%. But then a third
party candidate, Tiger, enters.
Tiger manages to convince 15% of the Leopard
voters to back him. Now the results are:
Under first past the post, gorilla now wins
even though a majority of the voters didn’t
want him.
Under the Alternative Vote, because all Tiger
voters put Leopard as second choice, Leopard
still wins because a majority of the citizens
of the animal kingdom would rather have her
in charge than gorilla.
With AV citizens can help support and grow
smaller parties that they agree without worrying
they’ll put someone they don’t like into
office.
After examining the differences, Queen Lion
decrees that the Alternative Vote is to be
the rule of the land for electing the king
and everyone is happier. …well almost everyone.
The two big parties can’t be complacent
and need to campaign harder for their votes.
This has been The Alternative Vote Explained
by me C. G. P. Grey.
Thank you very much for watching.